let's talk about what's going on in
afghanistan and the first thing i want
to address is
i was shocked by by uh the news
uh when when joe biden started giving
his speech and uh i was watching it i
was shocked to see how many people were
actually praising him i mean notably my
friend cassandra fairbanks when she said
it was a good speech not that it's
absolving him of responsibility of his
failures but at the very least look i
gotta say this he said a few things i
really did like and i think the
important thing about it why i'm going
to say thank you for saying these things
notably
we can't send americans to fight a war
the afghans are not willing to fight
themselves we were not supposed to be
nation building in afghanistan we cannot
pass this on to the next president and
we can't send another generation of our
men and women in uniform to go into this
quagmire this waste of money those are
good things because it vindicates a lot
of the anti-war positions of democrats
conservatives libertarians basically
everybody who've been saying the same
thing finally you get the president to
come out and say it that doesn't mean
he's done a particularly good job with
the withdrawal in fact a lot of people
are kind of shocked at how bad and
disastrous it was
surprisingly you know as i said earlier
i said in the intro the one thing that
he's getting praise for is the one thing
probably no one ever expected actually
speaking to be fair though not everybody
is giving him uh praise a lot of people
are saying that
it was a mixed bag he was blaming trump
he said well i inherited this deal it's
not my fault and the afghans are the
ones who don't want to fight
but the buck stops with me it's like all
right we'll just come out and say that
you made the decision i think ultimately
it was the right decision to leave
obviously bad things are happening but
uh you know with that i can i can
respect that we're getting out of
afghanistan russia you had you had
similar tweets i think you were yeah my
the point that i'm trying to make over
the past 36 hours is you know people who
are pushing around blame under
withdrawal i don't think the debate is
if the u.s should leave or not the
question is um why abandon the place
again most of my commentary over the
last 16 years has been on
politics here at home economics and the
politics of politics like i wouldn't say
that i'm that i have expertise in in the
military field but just you know
following a little bit with people
trying to push around blame between
trump and biden
um you know everyone says well trump had
a a plan to leave okay so there's a plan
to leave mean that we'll have this
disaster
my guess is that if trump were president
and the taliban were advancing over the
last few weeks he would pop off ten
tweets a day tell them one more step
these guys are making will drone them
and he would probably unleash hellfires
on them too hellfire missiles and they
will probably stop their advancement
um
you know the us for the last couple
years had only um
last year or so i think had only two and
a half thousand soldiers in afghanistan
and the peace was kept why is that it's
because people understood people on the
ground understood
that
the afghan government is underwritten by
the us underwritten by the u.s doesn't
mean the us needs to have
20 30 000 troops it means that the u.s
is there to give air support intel and
to take care of the bad guys
the problem here is not the withdrawal
it's abandoning the place as i said if
trump were in
i think we would probably see from him
dozens of tweets every day going back a
couple of weeks
warning them that one you know if they
go one more kilometer he'll smoke them
and he would probably smoke some of
these guys and they would stop
so yeah i agree so yeah i don't think
the you know i think michael tracy his
name is uh yeah so he yeah so he he made
the point that well uh any withdrawal
would be a disaster it would be
difficult
i don't know we had two and a half
thousand troops and now we have we sent
back seven to clean up the mess again i
i have no exp expertise in military but
work but uh seems strange so i don't
think every um defense department or
every administration would necessarily
execute
uh something you know is this this is
what kind of bums me out is
you know joe biden saying some of those
those things that i mentioned i'm like
thank you for saying that for america to
hear because now it's like what was that
about ron paul oh he was right what's
that about those who are opposed to this
war they were right but in the end it
just feels like
they're sitting in and they're sitting
in the you know a room going in a
meeting like what do we do how do we
address the american people and
someone's like i'm going to say whatever
they want to hear because we screwed
this up
i i but i want to say i agree with you
trump would have been bombing him he
would have he would correct i think
correct i think trump in in office
would have probably preserved some of
the gains
in other words
the damage of the way this withdrawal
was done is the way it was done
it's not preserving what you have and i
don't think you need necessarily troops
on the ground to preserve it
the understanding was
i think we can we can walk it back a
little bit to may the official deal was
that the u.s is going to leave in may
why didn't the taliban pop off in may
why did they wait until now
obviously there was some either
understanding on the ground or movement
by the u.s
that the taliban decided now it's time
to move so the u.s with a couple of
thousands of troops on the ground was
able to hold back the taliban
from may till now
which means they are probably they were
probably able to do that going forward
with some sort of a not even a
contingent of troops but again drones
or just being there and saying we are
going to defend this government and
don't you dare make any moves i think
people would listen as they did i think
the the the main issue is that it's
biden you know look obviously the
taliban china all these other countries
china's making fun of us we'll pull that
up in a little bit
they can see that we've got an economic
disaster we've got a border crisis we
had leaked audiotapes of majorca saying
you know we can't sustain the border
it's a disaster and effectively saying
we're going to lose control of this
and then you look at joe biden calling
uh you know uh shutting down press
events like not showing up going on
holiday
people are criticizing them constantly
gen saki's on vacation the taliban have
been seeing everything's been happening
with this and they're probably thinking
this administration is too weak to do
anything now is there opportunity
so i think with trump like you're right
you had been tweeting like a madman and
i definitely think
for better or for worse trump was viewed
by a lot of people around the world with
disdain and fear
because he was kind of erratic he was
kind of he was extremely arrogant and
aggressive and so you had this this you
know it's kind of a negative of
character right
but when you when you realize what that
means for the taliban they're thinking
this guy is insane because yeah
i think yeah i think trump strategically
decided you know the whole world is is
shivering every time kim jong-un is
going to do something trump figured well
i can be kim jong-un times over because
i'm the us we have a bigger military
bigger budget big means so if everyone
stops oh you know this madman is going
to go crazy you know what let me play
the same game again i haven't spoken to
him but it's just a guess the way he
behaved so what i'm saying is
withdrawing with this disaster just
means as china said you know that people
in hong kong or taiwan whatever should
know that the us is not going to be
there and and that's a distinction i
think we've we've been saying that about
taiwan for a minute that uh with the
escalation of rhetoric with you know uh
china sent in uh aircraft into the
taiwanese defense airspace i'm i'm
saying
biden's gonna do nothing i mean that
mark milley i i think is but let me but
let me ask you who who has appetite for
it
for
for yeah to to the years to take on
china i mean if diaz wants to take on
china china's main uh i would say
objective but the main tool that they
use is
economics they keep keep on investing in
in other countries they buy up
properties infrastructure they they lend
money to countries
we are busy you know i don't know
playing games here at home so
we we can pin it again i just want to
you know challenge a little bit of
thinking that biden wouldn't do but who
would do and who who would back it you
don't think trump would have lost his
mind and sent in a bunch of military i
think i i think there's there was a
smaller chance
of china doing something against taiwan
with trump than it is with biden or
someone else but again i'm not making
any military predictions i'm saying if
you look at china the last 20 30 years
their main objective around the globe i
think they even have deal with uh they
had to deal with afghanistan or pakistan
they have
i think they're announcing support for
the taliban correct they have support
all over the place and and in the u.s
you didn't have most people weren't even
with trump on the issue of
uh balancing out uh tariffs and and uh
important exports i want to i want to uh
paul biden's speech because i think we
as much as we can be happy that he said
things we got to call out the criticism
and we gotta we gotta hold him to his
word right so let me just read a couple
a couple of things he said
when i came into office i inherited a
deal that president trump negotiated
with the taliban under this agreement
u.s force would be out of afghanistan by
may 1st 2021 just a little little over
three months after i took office
u.s forces had already drawn down during
the trump administration from roughly 15
500 american forces to 2 500 troops in
the country and the taliban was its
strongest military since 2001. the
choice i had to make as your president
was either to follow through on that
agreement or be prepared to go back to
fighting the taliban in the middle of
the spring fighting season there would
have been no cease-fire there would be
no agreement protecting our forces after
may 1st there was no status quo
stability without american casualties
after may 1st there was only a cold
reality of either following through on
the agreement to withdraw our forces or
escalating the conflict and sending
thousands more american troops back into
combat in afghanistan and lurching into
a third decade of conflict i stand
squarely behind my decision after 20
years i've learned the hard way that
there was never a good time to withdraw
us forces that's why we're still there
we were clear-eyed about the risks we
planned for every contingency but i
always promised the american people that
i'll be straight with you
the question i have is as he goes on to
talk about american troops cannot and
should not be fighting into war and
fighting uh in a war and dying in a war
that afghan forces are not willing to
fight themselves does that apply to
every other country that the u.s has
military bases in does that apply to
syria should should we should we be
there if baidu wants to come out and say
these things that are going to be ear
candy to people who are anti-war i want
to see him actually put up and follow
through
and then yeah i mean the u.s has what uh
25 000 troops in in the korean peninsula
and uh so
if if biden's stance is that the the
country locally isn't willing to put up
a fight and therefore we should leave
then i guess the u.s can save a lot of
money yeah withdraw from from korea from
you know from from any player from japan
whatever you know
it is yeah it is in south korea whatever
it's it's it's an interesting point uh
that's why i don't think it's serious i
think what happened is
they inherited this deal and i think
they hate that they did i think you know
if trump didn't negotiate the withdrawal
because the american people wanted it i
guess what was it like trump came in on
like day three or whatever and told all
these people we're getting out of
afghanistan we're done with this i can't
remember who told us that and i think
they were they were mad about it but i
think biden did realize trump drew down
our forces to a degree we're going to
follow through but man
did they not plan for this i got i got
to say it they extended the timeline by
three months
clearly did not use that three months
for planning because the question
everybody has is why didn't they disable
the american military equipment why
didn't they blow it up or burn it or
destroy because they didn't do it all
these months because they were under the
illusion that afghan military is a legit
force and they'll use it
that's the problem
but i think but the counter-argument
that is okay that's why they didn't blow
up blow it up two three weeks ago but
why not over the last few days just blow
everything up if you anyway dealing with
a bunch of clowns you know yeah the
taliban doesn't have an air force i
guess now they do
and they could have uh just droned like
gotten rid of there's a meme going
around saying they got 166 blackhawks i
don't know if it's true but they were
like more than many other countries just
gave these these people these weapons
like yeah but i think yeah i think in
terms of military equipment uh you know
every year the there is the defense
authorization bill i think the last one
was 787 billion dollars
both parties in washington are willing
to continue continue to spend on
military hardware military
infrastructure
and there isn't any accountability in
other words accountability not if if a
defense contractor charges two dollars
more than they should per item it's just
like
who who decides like you know who who
who is accountable to whom when a
certain amount of humvees or apache
helicopters are sent overseas
remember remember that photo of isis
driving around that truck that had like
some american business printed on the
side of it gm i think
no no no no it's like a local plumbing
service i can't remember exactly what it
was but it was like how did that truck
end up in the middle like what is this
yeah i think a white pickup or something
yeah yeah something weird like that
normally they'll use nano thermite to
decommission vehicles when they're not
using anymore it's a military-grade
incendiary that'll melt the vehicle from
the inside yeah but in this case it's
like hey now they have some some
vehicles that we can figure out how to
destroy by building new weapons and now
we can
fund you know lockheed to do that thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you